I can ask you about the question up in
quite a lot and the question is,
will we have a limited amount of oil?
Well,
yes,
we do have limited amount of oil.
We have a limited amount of television
cameras and a Rolex watches and uh,
light bulbs and you name it.
There's a,
there's a finite number of everything.
My response to the peak oil,
uh,
arguments are,
okay,
so what,
yes,
we're going to hit a peak oil production
at some point in the future when that
is,
no one can predict.
But the point is that as the price of
oil rises,
entrepreneurs,
innovators are going to come up with new
ways to find oil and get it out of the
ground and further that the issue as
that,
as that price rises,
demand has to stay in balance with
supply.
You can't have more demand than supply
the price.
Eventually we'll,
we'll crush demand at a certain point
and they will,
they will stay in balance.
The good news for the u s which I think
is,
people may not say it's good news,
but we can afford higher oil prices more
easily than can't say Pakistan or India.
We are,
we're wealthier country.
We have more disposable income.
Um,
and so we are going to see as,
as oil or natural gas or any commodity
becomes more expensive.
Rolex watches,
they are rationed by price.
And in fact,
we have rationing by price.
Today on virtually every commodity.
Not everyone can eat at 21 club.
Not everyone wears a rolex.
Everything is rationed by price.
As energy prices rise,
we will see more pronounced rationing by
price of energy,
commodities.
And I think that that's inevitable.
The good news is that as the price
rises,
we'll see more innovation and more
alternatives come into the market,
whatever that may be,
whether it's batteries in cars or,
uh,
you know,
some other liquid fuel,
uh,
not ethanol,
that may come into the market.
Okay.